25 kilo sprengstoff sind in diesem auto
versteckt bomben zu finden das gehört
für sicherheitsleute zu ihrem job an
einer privaten berliner berufsschule
lernen sie wie es geht
was hier nur eine übung ist kann später
im beruf schnell ernst werden
in den letzten jahren sind auch in
deutschland die bombendrohungen häufiger
geworden
man muss natürlich schon ein bisschen
mühe überhaupt diesen ganzen beruf zu
machen aber man überlegt sich das wenn
man sich das überlegt dann müsste man es
auch so gut überlegen dass man wenn man
in so einer situation steckt auch weiß
jetzt können die clips machen und dann
war es das
damit muss man einfach darum gehen
können das sieht man auch er beiseite
im auftrag privater firmen schützen die
sicherheitskräfte personen oder
überwachen den öffentlichen raum
schulgründer torben meyer arbeitete
selbst 15 jahre lang bei der
militärpolizei der bundeswehr
er lässt keinen fehler durch tun denn im
realen leben gibt es keine zweite chance
wie willst du denn in die dunkelheit in
dem raum in dem in den motorraum willst
du das denn ohne taschenlampe sehen ob
dann draht gespannt ist er sagt ja da
ist bunt und ihr reist die haube auf und
schon sind wir alle weg wir sagen in der
sicherheitsbranche immer lass dir zeit
aber beeil dich dass man das wirklich
sauber kontrolliert und erst wenn man
weiß dass man wirklich sicher ist
dann öffnet man die haube wenn man sich
nicht sicher ist dann holt man sofort
die polizei die ausbildung dauert
mindestens drei monate die schüler
müssen auch körperlich fit sein
die kurse sind begehrt die industrie und
handelskammer bietet dreimal so viele
ausbildungsplätze an wie im letzten jahr
bis zu 5000 euro kostet ein lehrern
einen job ist anschließend so gut wie
sicher die nachfrage der unternehmen ist
hoch
also ich denke das sicherheitsbedürfnis
ganz klar gestiegen
steigt stetig ja das ist ja nicht mehr
wegzudenken das einzige was wir da
machen können ist präventivmaßnahmen
dass wir die sicherheit aufstocken das
wir sensibler sind dass wir dass wir
zweimal hingucken oder lieber drei mal
hingucken übung zur personenkontrolle
die angehenden security mitarbeiter
lernen menschen professionell zu
überprüfen
das abtasten gehört dazu leute wie sie
werden dringend gebraucht zum beispiel
am einlass von fußballspielen konzerten
und diskotheken
wir haben jetzt rund 300 offene stellen
die wir hier bewerben können in unseren
unternehmen für unsere teilnehmer die
unternehmen fragen wöchentlich neue
stellen und neue personen nach also auch
objektschutz spielt eine wichtige rolle
sprengstoff in einem gebäude
er kann in einem buch versteckt sein
oder im mülleimer
hier sind es nur attrappen die
sicherheitsleute sollen lernen genau
hinzusehen denn darauf kommt es in ihrem
job vor allem an